the border crisis coming to president
biden's doorstep governor greg abbott
making good on his promise to send
illegal immigrants from texas to
washington the first bus dropping
migrants off just blocks away from the
capitol abbott's move coming days after
the biden administration announced it
would put an end to title 42 which gave
border agents the authority to quickly
turn away large groups who tried to
enter illegally due to covet concerns
and now the chaos at the border is only
going to get worse one estimate says 140
000 migrants are waiting to cross once
title 42 is lifted jesse i was i have to
say i i wasn't sure since it has to be
voluntary uh if these migrants would say
yeah sure i want to go to washington d.c
and be dropped off at the steps of the
capitol and sure enough lucas tomlinson
our reporter was there watching it there
they are getting off the bus
look like they had like a decent ride
and it's not it's not these migrants
faults that we just we have no we have
no system
well an abbott dropped him off right in
front of the fox bureau
[Laughter]
smart move by governor abbott and he
knows what he's doing there uh and a
couple of these guys are from venezuela
they they said all right fine i'll go to
dc you know the first thing they did
when they got to dc they registered as
lobbyists
first thing they did and they're at cafe
milano right now trying to twist
mansion's arm and build back better i
swear to god not capital grill very very
they're going there tonight
they dress so nicely
athleisure one guy had matching nike
head to toe the kicks were clean if
you're fleeing a war-torn country
seeking asylum you think you're gonna
die and you show up looking that good no
one's gonna buy that soon as they get
here we dress them we put those clothes
on these people
come on americans don't dress this well
they don't give it to you look at that
guys sure look at the guy's skinny jeans
you can't show up to america claiming
you're fearing for your life dressed
that well it's not going to fly and
especially
they don't like stunts
they you know biden says oh we don't
like stunts the democrats love stunts
nancy's ripping up trump's state of the
union they're laughing their butts off
when they do the trump blimp oh that's
so funny come on don't you remember to
shame the press remember that texas
democrats who fled no yeah
here's the other thing greg that they
get here and then they just get to go
wherever they want i know this is i mean
it is a contrast to what's happening
with ukraine right yeah we admitted
legally 12 ukrainians last month
i mean why is my mother-in-law not on
that bus good point i don't know anyway
uh but is this it's an interesting
phenom this immigration problem is the
same
issue with crime and inflation it's it's
the problems get worse because they're
not exposed because the media acts as
like a consequence blanket they just
throw themselves over the outcomes of
the ruinous policies and and the again
the malignant neglect never gets covered
so what abbott does which is very clever
is he kind of forces them to cover it
right he sends the migrants to dc and
the media outside fox is in a quandary
do they cover this which means in their
audience sees the original problem the
original neglect or do they ignore it
and just abbott continues with his plan
which connects the dc population
directly with their destructive policies
so it's a very clever i don't even think
it's a stun i think it's a smart move
but it looks like the the migrants are
happy to be here they i
could tell that they were smiling with
their eyes
they were smizing they're smizing
everybody's learning to do that now with
the best yeah
i'm just glad they're wearing masks
geraldo
well i i think that governor abbott is a
great stuntsman i i i think that it's
not uh
necessarily a negative he's doing he's
he's doing what he thinks is right for
the his constituents in texas i think
between the abbott and the drones
there's no averting our eyes it's an
enormous enormous uh problem on the
southern border there's uh there's no
getting around the fact you mentioned
venezuela you can mention any of uh 200
countries people want to live in america
everybody wants to live here you need
some kind of system
that regularizes that normalizes i make
one on one point
here in this vast city had this one
incident with this uh this knucklehead
this uh terrorist there
when was the last time you heard of an
undocumented immigrant committing a
horrible crime
they are
disproportionately law abiding other
than the offense of coming from one of
them killed kate stein
one of them
[Music]
you know one of them
what about the per capita what about the
fact that so how do you want to admit 20
30 million are here no i don't want to
but i want you to know that these people
as you see
how many want to come and work how about
the unlike many native women they want
to work we just write about
[Music]
i just add a point and you can dismiss
it if you want
um so
apparently this plan though is already
working for the communities that were
asking abbott for help the communities
in texas
apparently according to the
fox news report
they many of those communities are
reporting already that the federal
government has stopped dropping
immigrants in their town since abbott
announced this yeah no it's about time i
think it's a good thing maybe not just a
stunt i think it's not a stunt i think
the ranchers have taken the bulk of the
the the problem here they're getting
their trust i've been down there three
or four times they're trespassing on
their property they're frightening
people the fences are broken they've got
drugs they've got human trafficking
they've got little children running
around let's not let's not party this up
but here's my favorite part i was
reading the news today and the uh the
director of coalition for the defense of
migrants says that the u.s government
has provided preferential treatment to
the ukrainians can you imagine is that's
just so unfair i mean they are people
who really need to understand
now and let me just finish and you said
we need a system that with regularities
and that normalizes we have a system
it's called the immigration system it's
called you get a visa you get a lawyer
you want your turn online you swear
allegiance to the united no i'm not
going you swear allegiance to the united
states of america and then maybe we'll
let you in line and if you can take care
of yourself and your family and i'll
tell you where the next bus should go i
wanted to go to nancy pelosi's house
san fran i have to defend geraldo on
this part because later in the show
we're going to be doing something on
california having a four-day exact wake
and we're going to be seeing more of
this universal base income the people on
that bus are going to the people who are
actually going to be working
these people are as opposed to americans
we're having a serious problem hiring
even here everywhere we go people are
having a hard time finding people that
will take a job yeah when are you going
to talk about the the delivery guys the
dishwashers the babysitters the lawn
mowers
if they come here they get the papers
you let them in they can't just walk in
and say yeah i'm here now we're working
out each of them had some kind of uh ngo
some kind of uh you know organization
all right hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else